qu'est ce que vous retenez votre
gouvernement
plusieurs choses d'abord les poids
lourds du gouvernement restent toute
l'architecturé
principal de l'ancien gouvernement reste
on a toujours gérald darmanin bruno le
maire sébastien lecornu aux armées pap
ndiaye à l'éducation était donc
larchitecture qui était connu et que les
gens avaient peut-être intégrer demeure
ensuite y'a pas d'élargissement
politique il n'ya pas de personnalité de
prise de guerre comme comme il y en a eu
en revanche s'il ya une
comment dire les alliés du parti
présidentiel qui sont confortés je pense
à horizon d'edouard philippe puisque
christophe béchu à un nouveau
portefeuille celui d'amélie de
montchalin sur la transition écologique
ça c'est assez importante mais la
cohésion des territoires et la cohésion
des territoires
il y à des personnalités comme
caroline cayeux qui est effectivement
proche des territoires qui rentrent
aussi ça c'est pour les territoires donc
voilà il ya un profit plutôt à ces
politiques poids lourds politiques et
techniques je vois que ce qui rentre et
qui n'étaient pas forcément attendus
sont des gens qui sont spécialistes de
leur spécialité le nouveau ministre
compte par exemple de l'art de la santé
est quelqu'un qui avait fait la mission
flash donc effectivement on peut
imaginer que lui sera à même d'aller
trouver le bon
ton mais
voilà qui remplace damien abad donc
voilà il ya des personnalités assez
comme ça spécifiques et technique y
rentrer et puis je retiens aussi
effectivement le départ de damien abad
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas une petite
information
sachant que la ministre
qui sont loués boulazac enfin quand même
s'il s'est entraîné
elle est donc effectivement c'est un
petit peu ouais poids deux mesures voilà
pour les grands les grands éclairage de
ce gouvernement on va évidemment revenir
dans le détail
on trouve que c'est un gouvernement qui
finalement prendre acte que la situation
parlementaires et
les désirs les déclarations des
oppositions ne lui permettent pas
d'élargir sa base majoritaire c'est
surtout cela je crois qui est frappant
dans la composition de ce gouvernement
ça a été dit on voit que il n'ya aucun
transfuge en dehors de cette majorité
qui rentre dans ce gouvernement donc
tout se passe comme si finalement le
président de la république et la
première ministre prenait acte
finalement d'une situation
parlementaires qui ne leur permettent
pas de calais alors permettez pas
d'aller plus avant dans une
recomposition politique ce qui est quand
même assez frappant c'est que si vous
voulez
l'attractivité de ce qui était la marque
macron en 2017
ou tout au long même de ce quinquennat
précédent semble aujourd'hui quelque
part c'est rodez parce que finalement il
s'agit d'un gouvernement qui se traduit
par un repli sur sont réduits historique
d'une certaine manière parce qu'il ne
peut pas faire autrement en l'occurrence
clairement donc il en prend acte ensuite
en effet alors il ya quelques signaux à
droite on voit qu'il ya des
personnalités plutôt politiques issus du
monde de la droite qui sont promus
madame cayeux on en a parlé monsieur
béchu également une petite peste et à
gauche avec l'arrivée du maire de clichy
de clichy de clichy-sous-bois quelques
personnalités dites de la société civile
comme monsieur brawn ou monsieur combes
mais tout cela finalement j'allais dire
ne constitue pas une profonde nouveauté
sur le plan politique et ça traduit
finalement que les marges de manoeuvre
se sont quand même considérablement
réduite et elle se sont donc d'autant
plus réduite que le résultat des listes
hâtif et celui que l'on connaît ouais
bruno cautrès nouveau gouvernement c'est
finalement le signe de l'affaiblissement
de la macro niais
mais je rejoins mes camarades dont la
tonalité générale effectivement un signe
d'une dune ma chronique y maintenant
fonctionne à la fois sur ses ressources
de deux débats et des ministres
maintenant qu'ils vont être en poste
depuis le tout début depuis 2010 est ça
commence ça commence à faire un bail et
puis aussi des bons élèves de la
majorité on voit des députés aussi qui
montent maintenant au niveau du du
gouvernement quelques élus locaux mais
effectivement nous on ne voit toujours
pas très très bien la grande ligne
directrice la grande histoire que ce
nouveau gouvernement est en train de
raconter aux français au fond saphir la
dimension avant tout technique je dirais
que c'est une équipe de 2,2 réformateur
réparateur au fond il n'ya pas vrai
véritablement de on va dire de ligne
directrice ni politique ni idéologique
on ne voit pas très bien non et qu'elle
est là qu'elle est là comment tout ceci
peut peut constituer un point de départ
pour une recomposition au cours du
mandat d' emmanuel macron donkey il
faudra aller voir leur effectivement
faut être patient et attendre un peu de
voir ce que va en ce qu'on veut de
donner à l'automne les premiers crash
pièce au fond lorsqu'on va avoir les
premiers textes qui vont venir en
délibération et plus tard en veux tu en
voilà ce que je retiens rien que c'est
le côté revenant c'est le retour de
certains mis du premier quinquennat dans
ce nouveau gouvernement alors pour des
raisons politiques avec des ministres
modem qui font leur retour notamment
geneviève darrieussecq qui étaient aux
anciens combattants qui va maintenant
être en charge des personnes handicapées
hier à sara lee qui a été réélu député
en loire-atlantique jeune secrétaire
d'état modem qui retrouve et bien ce
portefeuille en charge de la jeunesse
puis et surtout marine ça parle qui
était quand même une figure médiatique
du premier quinquennat d'emmanuel macro
on savait qu'elle ne serait pas et bien
dans le premier gouvernement de ce
second quinquennat et finalement elle
fait son retour alors est-ce que c'était
son souhait ce qui est à noter en tout
cas du côté de match passée qu'elle
était ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté dans le premier quinquennat
et là elle revient aux biens au statut
de secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'économie associatif c'est assez rare
quand même que quelqu'un passe de
ministres et secrétaires d'état dans le
protocole
[Musique]